un an et demi de travaux et voilà le
café de la plage transformer celui de
spectacles historiques de vos repas a
fait peau neuve
un espace plus grand 900 m² au total la
création d'une deuxième salle de
spectacle du matériel rénové une
meilleure acoustique et même des espaces
en backstage
comme ces loges qui n'attendent plus que
leurs artistes que ce soit oldelaf qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur la scène du café
où les joyeux urbains
jim murple mémorial qui est déjà passé
plusieurs fois sur la structure quoi
vous dire d'autre
arnaud tsamère qui on vient nous faire
le plaisir d'une carte blanche et bien
entendu tous les groupes locaux des
artistes locaux donc et des stars comme
jamel qui a parrainé l'inauguration de
vendredi dernier
la programmation est déjà bouclée
jusqu'en juillet première date le 1er
mars pour chaud l'hiver
un festival avec des artistes membres de
cobalt
le studio d'enregistrement de la ville
un clin d'oeil aux partenariats à venir
avec les différents acteurs jeunesse de
maurepas c'est un projet jeunesse qui va
se développer également sur des projets
transversaux avec les autres structures
jeunesse de la ville
il va y avoir également des projets
intergénérationnels sur cette structure
là et c'est un lieu où on fait de la
prévention également auprès de la
population jeunes de la ville dans cette
optique la toute nouvelle structure
accueille également la boutique infos
jeunes ouverte au public depuis mardi